we've had discussions where like we're
the same in every way and i mean every
way
if you know what i mean so oh my gosh
it's so funny
so we know
i'm the prettier twin three
two one go that is good
we've been told this i mean i'm not
trying to be like a
mean person but like i mean we have been
told it multiple times told what that
i'm
he's better looking okay so obviously
people have said
yeah like different periods like people
say oh she looks better than me or
people will say i look better than her
like we've been told
we've been told that through our lives
but it's always like in and out but it's
never like we
think that about each other i feel like
we both admire
our differences about each other she's
beautiful and i think she's so pretty so
it's like we're stable
she's my best friend like we never do
that like also
yeah i don't know it's weird yeah there
have been times sometimes
where i'm like oh i'm wearing this and
you're wearing like
a sport jersey and i'm like
like it's not really a common thing it
doesn't happen a lot but sometimes it'd
be like i would never wear that
you do you my friend i agree with you
then again what are those kicks you're
wearing right there my man oh my crocs i
don't know
well we have this saying like if i'm
ugly then she's ugly so we're both ugly
like
it's like a little thing like if someone
says brother like oh they must think the
other one's ugly or something you know
it makes me feel like because like
if i wasn't a twin no one be comparing
my weight or my
leg look like i would just be my own
self and like i just like want my beauty
to be like
people to think i'm like just as pretty
as her so it kind of would make me feel
like crap about myself oh no don't cry
i don't cry because people would be like
oh your eyes are smaller than hers or
something and i would be like are my
eyes small like
i would get confused yeah well i say
there's like one bad too bad
all right so we had our audience submit
hot tapes
which is assumptions that they have
about your group
here we go people always want to have
threesomes with us
[Music]
of course i mean down san diego doesn't
happen
maybe in l.a it's a big thing here but
we've never been asked that question
never been asked that in my life well
we've like gotten
uh many and hundreds of requests like on
social media and our twin thing and um
we actually almost did it one time
one time we were going to but then we
were like you know what
yeah we've been asked we just like
walked away and that'd be really blunt
though
no not like a few times where like three
people were like so twins right we're
just like
i think it's crazy maybe thinking you're
dead oh you guys think it's weird i
think it's like
literally i would i would do it if the
dude was submissive
she said she was oh you guys would i
think i was submissive i love it
do it yeah if you're a game i mean i
mean we've seen each other naked i mean
it doesn't matter why would i touch you
i would never want to touch her like
that no no we wouldn't touch each other
we have the same penis or boob size
i mean i don't really know i don't pay
attention when he like i don't really
know
we're very similar we're the same height
same
like everything is the same um yeah
i mean like i've seen her naked but i
don't stare at her boobs we okay we wear
the same
we can fit each other's clothes yeah
yeah i don't know the exact cup
measurements i feel like your boobs are
bigger than mine but we can still like
the same stuff yeah i think we're the
same i i think we've had discussions
where like we're the same in every way
and i mean every way
if you know what i mean so oh my gosh
it's so funny
so we know i have felt
jealous of my twin three
two one go
for me i have again i was more like
younger i did compare myself
a lot to my sister because in high
school i guess she was like
the other twin that got more attention
from like boys some friends
and i was like why don't i get the same
attention as she does
and then so i have felt jealous in the
past but not anymore
well i disagree obviously because i
haven't felt like that but um i think we
look the same i've never like looked at
her and be like
oh wow she looks better than me and i
makes you sad that she felt like that
before but
i look at her selfie sometimes i think
that's me and it's kind of scary
she's done that before too creepy it's
kind of creepy but um yeah so if we want
to boil it down to it it's like
sometimes we like the same girl and then
her be talking to her and i'll be in the
corner being like and you feel upset
or like a friend will talk to you like
more than me i feel like oh
they like him more i'm not as loved but
i do think it's
that's twins will always feel always be
compared
by outside outsiders and just even in
in between themselves but i think i'm
not like particularly jealous
at all like at the end of the day like
like we're both
we are both super similar but we're
individuals and like i love him for his
like his differences and he loves me for
my differences so
yeah you know um i put somewhat disagree
because during the pandemic
i started struggling with like social
anxiety a lot and i had never struggled
with it before
i had always considered myself to be
super super extroverted
i'm very extroverted i could just like
talk to anyone but during the pandemic i
was just
suffering really badly with like anxiety
and stuff so i guess i started to have a
lot of self-loathing towards myself
and i couldn't i was really happy at one
point she was really happy when i was
really struggling i just
i felt alone i was like i don't know how
to deal with this
yeah i struggle with my
identity as a twin three
two one go
i wouldn't say i like i think struggle
is a very strong word
like i don't mind being a twin like i
think it's cool being a twin and stuff
like that
but i also have like a want to like know
what it's like to like
just be myself and that's why i told i
literally told them don't go to the same
college as me
like we got into the same university and
we were like i was like nah go somewhere
else
it's like i just want to try it you know
like because like i've been a twin all
my life i want to see what it's like to
like
not be a twin or at least like notice
like to be like
known as tyler instead of twin or
johnson twins or brothers or whatever so
i don't struggle with my
i feel like like my individuality but i
think other people do
it's like they see us and they group us
together and i'm pretty sure it's the
same for everybody
so i know who i am he knows who he is
but like people
can't really separate it's hard for
people to separate us you know since
they're so similar i've gotten
comfortable with like not really
going out and like like finding out what
i am personally who i am
so um as a twin we're just like used to
being
together and like like the same things
and we're comfortable at that i know who
i am we're completely different people
well
i'm not like that but um i would say
that i don't like
strongly know who i am so that's really
why i would say somewhat disagree so
yeah
yeah i feel the same way i feel like
since i'm still like in like
codependent kind in a way i don't really
really venture out or go
out of my comfort zone of like things
that i would normally do without her
so since i'm not with her i wouldn't do
i guess
uh interest that i might have outside of
her yeah
i think for us too we pretty much
embraced the twin yeah we like we love
being twins we think it's lucky that we
were able to be doing so we think it's a
blessing and we
we've never been more than like eight
hours and a day apart from each other
we've never split up it's because
sometimes we get like separation anxiety
and we kind of had like a lot of stuff
happening
in our childhood we like lost family
members yeah we like to always meet
again where the other one is so
oh oh oh slapper no i'm just
kidding yeah we go we fight a lot we say
each other the hospital before
we'll fight
and i had braces and she swung it and
hit me in the face yeah like i will
i knock her braces went through her
cheeks and then one time i curved
stopped her head and she got neck shots
at the hospital
we get aggressive with each other we
view ourselves as like a married couple
you know
married couples argue married couples
don't you know
sometimes i wish i wasn't a twin
three two one
i think sometimes i wish i was in a twin
and certain things because i didn't
choose to be a twin so it's kind of like
forced into this twin ship sometimes i
do wish like oh you know
what if i actually split up you know
what if i you know wasn't a twin or
didn't you go into somewhere else
different or move somewhere else so
sometimes i don't really like it because
of society not because of her it's
because of society like
a lot of singletons that's what we call
like regular people
like the singletons they don't
understand they always ask like what is
it like being a twin and i say
you know imagine you're a singleton in a
world full of twins
what that would feel like for you the
world is designed for singletons not for
twins
i like being twins because i think it's
like we're like really close sisters i
really like our relationship
like we talk all the time and i think i
wouldn't trade that sister bond for the
world and like
um i feel like because we have such a
unique experience because we look alike
and share the same dna i feel like we
like are so
we're closer than other sisters i think
and yeah i just like being a twin i
think it's fun
i think it's like unique and different
he'd be pissing me off sometimes so it's
like bro
sometimes you wish he wasn't a twin but
then it's like like i said he'd be
pissing me off so i don't even want to
like
be near him no i don't care about like
him pissing me off i could just go
somewhere
else that's not why i'm just i think
it's more curiosity thing for me
like what it's like to be a singleton or
whatever
my whole life i've been known as twins
instead of me so i'm just curious
i would die without her i don't i die
without you yeah i literally idiot
yeah that's a dark thought yeah it's so
sad i
absolutely love it it's having a
permanent best friend for my entire life
uh i can talk to him whenever i want
he's like my emotional
pull i can lean on it's i don't know i i
just
there's just nothing that would ever
make me like oh i don't want to do this
anymore
because like you're never alone wherever
you go
i'm the same way the only reason i said
disagree not strongly disagree is it can
be a little tough sometimes that be
that we're seen as that package deal and
that can be a little frustrating to not
that's hard time to break out your shell
and be like i am well yeah no we start
with breaking out of like
if we're in a social setting we just
cling to each other yeah that's like
we're not
we're not introverted but we're like
it's it's easy to
just if i'm in a setting where i don't
feel as comfortable just to be like all
right i'm talking only to him
[Music]
thank you
you